each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so everyone thank you for joining us
this afternoon the you are insane
talents in the future web track where we
have three sessions this one that was
one on intelligence and this afternoon
we're going to focus on privacy and
Trust we have two speakers for this
session money now are and Jeffrey
Freiburg we're going to start with mony
and it's a great pleasure i'll introduce
them separately one at a time to first
introduce money who is going to talk
about pan privacy so money comes from
israel vitamin institute you are so
familiar with the u.s. you've been have
you spent quite a few times like doing
your studies are in berkeley and many
owners and in the interest of time I'm
going to let you start now thank you
I'm going to talk about privacy of
dynamic data continual reservation in
fam privacy this is a joint work with
stupid work tourniquet a cigar off
blooming sooo gay honey and a lot of
this work was actually done at a
Microsoft Silicon Valley Cynthia and
Sergey are there and the guy and Tony
and I were a visiting so what is privacy
so it's really a screw me over loaded
term and very hard to define even when
you know what you want and a lot of
people who've actually tried to define
it decided it's too complex and gave up
and I guess this is a good is definition
as you can get privacy's like oxygens
you're on the feel it when they're when
it's gone but still I have to tell you
what given that it's an overloaded you I
have to tell you what what aspect of
privacy i'm going to talk about so we
know that there is lots of data around
and it's available to companies into
government agencies the form of census
data in here for instance if you wonder
whether people are interested in privacy
or not here simply the law mandates say
privacy in the law mandates that you not
reveal a individual data there is a huge
database collected by companies it's
known as the data deluge a there's lots
of public surveillance information from
cameras from RFIDs from others and now
in more recently social networks give
you a lot of information and the the
natural question is exactly what do you
do in terms of privacy in all with all
this information so we know that
statistical data analysis gives you a
can give you a lot of benefits who can
find correlations for in for instance in
medical studies you can provide better
services
in web search and fit adds to queries
which has certainly has the social
values you have to publish official
statistics a data mining of course but
data contains confidential information
in almost any usage of the data that is
not carefully crafted we leak something
about it and definitely if we have
better privacy we'll have we expect to
get better data from mare people so here
is an here is a bad example a pretty
famous they are in search history
release so a few years ago AOL decided
to release a it's a search log for the
goal was to provide real query logs from
real users which were not available at
that time and what they did is they
removed what they thought was
identifying information there whenever
there was a username they replaced it
with where there unidentified but
different searches to the same by the
same user was still linked and they
didn't take long until someone until
they the New York Times managed to find
actually a specific user who's complete
search history was revealed it was a
lady laughs elma Arnold and cheated a
lot of interesting searches as you can
see and and she also had a good
explanation for it and of course once
you once you know when once you have
someone search history given that people
do vanity searches and various other
reasons it's not that difficult to
figure out there who they are so this is
a bad example simply removing the name
of an individual from from the search is
not a it's not a good way to preserve
privacy so it is a it is a hard question
if it's a hard question
how to do how to do how to get in
privacy when you have rare public data
analysis and what we're interested in is
getting the utility of statistical
analysis while protecting the privacy of
every individual participants and still
we want we want the sort of the
sanitized the data that will provide to
allow reasonably accurate answers to me
too and to meaningfully queries and one
question is whether it's possible at all
to define this goal and to define and
achieve it in any meaningful way in the
best answer that we have for that was
actually suggested by Microsoft
researchers by aid work mature in ec min
smith a working material microsoft nice
a mincemeat were visiting that anything
actually is also at microsoft now and
they defined a differential privacy so
whether the definition of differential
privacy protects individual participants
so you have on the red and the red you
have a some sort of data you have a
curator or a sanitizers that wants to
produce a sub sanitized version of it
like very well what they are welded by
removing real names but of course in a
good way so the sanitizer produces the
green version on on the right and the
idea the definition of the differential
privacy talks about the difference
between a database and an ADA base plus
an individual and the girl is that there
it will be hard to distinguish between
the case where the individual added
individual is in the database and it is
in the case where it is not in the
database okay so these two cases should
look similar a given a sanitized version
will be hard to say whether that
individual
the database or not so em in particular
what it means that is we want to want is
the probability of every bad event any
event or any event we snap doesn't have
we don't have to say what is bad so yeah
the probability of any event increases
only by small a small multiplicative
factor when that individual enters the
base as compared to when it is not in
the database and therefore from that
individuals point of view it may as well
participate in the database if it
doesn't reveal if its participation
cannot be deduced from their output so a
little bit more mathematically what you
want is that for all databases d for all
individuals me for all possible outputs
see the difference oops you can see some
problems with Microsoft the two should
have been in a so the probability that
the output of the sanitizer is in some
belongs to some subset T versus when the
individual isn't their database versus
the probability that that it is the
output is in T when it is not in the
database that should be between e to the
apps to eat to the minus epsilon and a
to the epsilon so roughly 1 plus epsilon
so that's a excellent differential
privacy epsilon cannot be too small it
cannot be negligible for those of you
with a crypto background there but I
think of a small constant that's their
the best way so just to a familiar
familiar ourselves with this notion
let's see an example of what is not
differential privacy so let's say we
have a very simple database against the
again the two is a in so we have a set
of the day of X of names of database
that is a name and the tag which is 0 or
1 and we really want to release a single
query a which is the number of
participants where where the
tag is one so here here is something
that is typically done in in many cases
and that's released a few random couples
with no name okay so you do a sampling
and remove their you sample and remove
the name so that is actually not
differentially private because we
because it's suppose that there is only
a single individual with a with the tag
is one all the rest are 0 in this case
he has some probability that you will be
the output let's say one over N or some
small constant over n where n is the
number of participants so if is in the
database the probability of having a one
in the in the sample is 1 over N but if
it's not in the database the probability
of 0 therefore we have no a no
differential privacy for any epsilon so
sampling and releasing information about
in a sampling and simply releasing that
information is not differentially
private on the other hand what we can do
is add the noise which which is
carefully designed this is this is what
we'll actually do you can do a lot and
that is we add noise chosen we simply
output the number of ones pleasant ways
and the noise is chosen from a laplacian
distribution with parameter 1 over
epsilon so it's like the exponential
this distribution but a symmetric and
the key property the key nice property
of the laplacian distribution is the
probability that the noise is a k minus
1 is something like e is e to the
epsilon times the probability that noise
is k so it differences by one are
exactly absorbed by by by they see the
best you can do review if you want to
know whether individual is in the
database or not the best you best say
the best day by as you can get is e to
the epsilon so this is a good trick so
we can release we can always add noise
which is distributed according to this
distribution and the not fair cause too
much damage now the desirable properties
that we want from a sanitization
mechanism is that is composability so if
you apply the sanitization several times
you have some sort of graceful
degradation and in fact a epsilon
differential privacy has exactly this
property so if you release if you make Q
releases and each of them epsilon
differentially private then you'll get a
Q times epsilon differential privacy
privacy all together so you have to set
epsilon of course accordingly if you
know the dark you so other notions for
instance of rare they try to protect
their privacy have do not have this
property if you know about canon omit e
if you release it twice you it may be
gone completely gone and then robustness
suicide information we don't need to
specify exactly what the adversary knows
we said it knows everything except
whether whether that individual is in
the database or not okay so so now what
the questions that we consider it is
what happens if the data is dynamic so
we want to handle situations where the
data keeps changing and not all the data
is available at the time of sanitization
so we have part of the database coming
and then you have to perhaps output and
other part comes and then you have to
output something else etc so we still
want to have differential privacy in
such cases and think of one example is
think of Google Trends their life for
instance they like to advertise the fact
that they can track what happens with
the flu so they give from their query
log they we want to produce they want to
report the popularity of various queries
at any point in time and from that
presumably you can deduce where where
the flu weather is whether whether that
where there is a whether there is a flu
epidemic where the flu epidemic appears
etc and therefore there the data that
they have the number of queries about
about flu related keywords that keeps
changing in time that always changes and
they don't know all the data when
they're producing it so they cannot it's
not the original picture we had in mind
by the latter picture where the data
keeps coming in and you want to output
to make some sort of output so now there
are lots of fish that come up so one
issue is continual observation the
adversary gets to examine the output of
the sanitizer all the time not just at
the end or another issue is what we call
pan privacy and here the issue it's more
general than just for google trends the
point is that there can be real kinds
where the adversary gets to examine the
internal state of the sanitizer perhaps
it broken into their into the system or
perhaps agadi subpoena so we have to
consider what happens what exactly we're
storing about individuals even in the
internal state not only about not in
only in there the output in another
issue that comes up is what exactly are
we protecting what is the unit that
we're protecting what is an individual
is it an event level or user level I
will demonstrate it more a more detail
later on and the issue the point is that
now given that the data keeps changing
it's much less clear what exactly is an
individual you can't simply sort them
together you have to say things more
explicitly so let's talk about continual
output observation so the data is a
stream of items and the sanitizer sees
each item and updates its unit internal
state and produces an output observable
to their adversary the adversary is
there the entity that tries to decide
whether individual is in the database or
not so here we have the here we have the
the stream and here we have the state of
their sanitizer the sanitizer reach the
first part of the stream and sanitizers
and produce
an output and changes its internal state
accordingly and so on so it reads
something produces an output and changes
its state and so on so at the first cut
what were what the unit which were
protecting is one square later on the
this is the event level and later on
they the user level think of it that we
were trying to protect the color trying
to protect all the yellow ones are all
the weather there is a yellow one in
there in the stream or not whether there
is a green one in the stream or not but
right now we're talking about protecting
just a one square so in a continual
observation where again interested in
differential privacy and they we are
talking about adjacent to data streams
with where we can get from one to
another by a changing a singular element
and as before we say that an algorithm
or a sanitizing algorithm is a epsilon
differentially private against continual
out but if we're all adjacent their data
stream justin is prime for all possible
prefixes there are prefix of the output
signal one up to a sigma t the the ratio
between the probabilities weather in of
these two strings of these two adjacent
strangest between e to the minus epsilon
in e to the epsilon and here is a land
here is a simple problem to the chair we
can do which is a counter let's say that
we have a counter think of youtube view
on youtube you can see how many people
watched a certain video and listen
general you may think it because it's an
aggregated number then it's safe to
release but in general this is a very
dangerous thing to to have exact numbers
it's always a dangerous thing just think
of a simple database if you allow to
queries I in general a one query where
one
re which includes me in another query we
but includes me together with a very
large set at another query which just
includes that large set but without me
then of course by subtracting the two
results if it's let's say counting query
you'll be able to deduce my value so
general giving accurate results is
always a very dangerous thing so here
we're trying we're trying to have a
counter like in YouTube that will would
not reveal let's say whether I've
watched the video or not you've sent me
a link to the video and you're
interested in knowing whether it watch
that video or not and if you follow the
counter you if no precaution is legend
you may be able to deduce whether I've
watched it or not so the question is how
can we so we have a stream is 0-1 stream
it's relatively sparse number and we
want to always have a publicly
observable counter that approximates the
number of one's seen so far and a at
each point each time period that the
output would should be there should it
should be close to the total number of
ones and as I said we want to hide
individual increments while providing a
reasonable accuracy okay so here is an
example we have well and we've seen one
we have to output something let's say
we're output one we still output one we
still output one here we output 2 and of
course this was a completely in this
case it was a completely accurate one
but we want to mask this so that the
adversary would not be able to deduce
when the increments a occurred so here
is a so here is a simple idea I think of
each time period you have input which is
either 0 or 1 output the counter by
input X I and add we saw that laplacian
noise is so good at laplacian noise with
magnitude 1 over epsilon so i will have
privacy since
each increment is protected by laplacian
noise we'll get it will actually be
differentially private whether X I 0 or
1 so that for privacy point of view it's
good what about accuracy well the
accuracy the noise cancel out we're
going to have if we have a sequence of
length capital T then we're going to add
T such things it will cancel out but
we'll still have an error of square root
of T now remember that this is a
relatively sparse sequence so square
root of T Square p capital T is the
total number of the time periods so
square root of K could be a pretty large
number a given that we have sparse
things so we want to do that we want to
do better than the square root of T and
why were we so accurate essentially a we
operated completely as say a little more
about randomized response but we acted
exactly is in the random is response we
didn't utilize at all the fact that we
do have a state that they we do have an
internal state maybe even an external
but definitely an internal state we each
each data item was completed completely
independently and we acted exactly the
same in cases where the data was sparse
and when when it was dense and of course
we have to be very careful because the
times when the counter is updated our
potential leakage so here is an idea
that can improve it quite substantially
the idea is to apply conversion form
static algorithm into a dynamic one so
we'll have many will have many
accumulators with run in parallel and
each one of them counts the number of
ones in a fixed segment of time plus
some noise so each accumulator is in
charge of a particular segment a segment
which is a set ahead of time and of
course a when we actually use it will
use it plus noise the value of the
counter at any point in time is some of
accumulators of a few segments okay so
accumulator is may
the accumulator accumulates when the
segment goes on but then when it is
finished only then it is going to be
used only when when when the segment
that it measures is they completed so a
the accuracy depends on the number of
segments in the summation and the
accuracy of the of the accumulators so
at any point in time what we sum up to
say to give our estimated any in point
in time we're going to sum up a few
hopefully a few because it affects the
accuracy but we're going to sum up a few
accumulators and say the given time so a
the privacy depends on the number of
accumulators at the point influences so
for accuracy we want each we want each a
each point in time to be expressed as
the sum of a few segments and for
privacy we want each point in time to
intersect a few segments so these are a
contradictory requirements somewhat
contradictory in the best thing we can
do is a base rate on the bit
representation of a of the time T so
each point in time participates in in in
the something like a log T segments and
and the Sun at each point in time is
going to be the sum of it most log T
accumulators ok so so H so we'll have
segments for each for every power of two
will have a will have a segment and we
want when we want to sum up and we want
when we want to sum up a given point we
look at the bit representation it choose
the segments accordingly and get the sum
so e so again we have to sum at most log
T segments and each point participates
in at most log key segments so if we set
epsilon prime to be something like
epsilon over a log T ignore the one over
work and we can get we can get the
desired privacy we'll get to epsilon
privacy so we have to reduce epsilon 2 x
factor of log T and in terms of accuracy
will get the accuracy instead of square
root T that went before something like
log to the 1.5 ba over epsilon because
again will have their some consolation
so we have we can have a camera the
conclusion is that we can have a counter
with a reasonable accuracy in this in
this way so the accurate that will have
epsilon differential privacy and the
accuracy would be something like log to
the 1.5 p in actually log tease them is
the best you can do we don't know
exactly what happens between log 10 log
to the lock to the 1.5 key okay so this
is this is an example of something you
can do with the continual output now
once you have a counter you can do lots
of things with a counter I'm not going
to tell you think much about it i'll
just mention for instance you can do
aggregations of expert advice while
keeping the expert opinion in private so
you can run with learning algorithm that
aggregate experts advice while keeping
what the actual expert said privately so
let's talk about the other issue there
Pam privacy so usually the data curator
is trusted but of course even
well-intentioned curators of sanitizer
is subject to a mission creep to
subpoena to security breach to lots of
other things and a you can think of
various example stories they like not as
a thoroughly bad one from the law
abiding citizens point of view like the
story of a basic professional baseball
player a collection of the drug tests it
was supposed to be a secret but was
actually subpoenaed etc so the curator
accumulates
secure information but should never
store sensitive data so at any point in
time even if its state is leaked it
shouldn't be too disastrous that's the
go in the game they could reassure
individuals that they have no reason to
fear from participating in from the data
being in that setting because even if
things go wrong it can't be too bad and
we call this property pound privacy
because the algorithm is private both
inside and out and so right over so
there is an example of such a thing and
that's called the randomized techniques
of Stanley Warner from the mid 60s where
we decided where we designed a method
for polling stigmatizing questions the
idea is that you ask the participants to
lie with Mary probability so the
specific answers are some were deniable
but the aggregate results are still
valid and the data is never stored in
the clear and this this really this
technique is very popular nowadays in
the database literature starting from
that work of agri world into account and
more recent work by mishra and forgot
annabelle a so the good thing here is
that you don't have to trust the curator
because it never stores you just add the
noise yourself individualized annoys
them self a the point is that it's good
only for very limited type of tasks in
particular if the same individual
appears in this picture several times
then then the privacy is gone because
you will be able to average out the
noise that he adds and also it's clear
that you can do very limited well it
maybe it's not so clear but you can show
that you can do only relatively limited
amount of computation in this sort of
the individual himself has to add the
noise and you get no chance of fair
interacting but we are interested in
more complex things so in particular
think of it think of our with it we have
a stream of user
names and query query as in search query
and we do not want to expose anything
about a particular user only and not
only about a particular user query pair
but about a particular user so the fact
that we want to hide all the all the
queries that the user specific user it
should is the user level if we were only
hiding a particular pair of user query
then it would have been event level so
of course doing a user level it's more
challenging given that we don't want to
store anything private but actually you
can do they show is can you do any sort
of aggregation without storing sensitive
data and and the answer is the case you
can do some things you can definitely do
some interesting things we don't quite
know we don't have a good
characterizations of what you can do but
definitely you can do some interesting
things so again in the pan privacy model
as before the the data is a stream of
items they the sanitizers reads them one
at a time and we're now because we're
interested in user level protection
we're trying to hide all similar colored
squares so we want to hide all the
information in the blue squares or all
information which it shouldn't be able
given the output or given the internals
given the output and the internal stake
it shouldn't be possible to determine
whether the blue whether the blue
squares appeared at all or not okay so
there for every possible behavior of the
user in the stream the Joint
Distribution of the internal state at
any single point in time and they find
well we're also interested in continual
observation in the final output or
although all the possible outputs should
be differentially private we can also
talk about multiple intrusions not a
single intrusion but let's concentrate
in a single intrusion that's bad enough
and so as we said we're talking about
adjacency where you have two streams
the two streams are considered adjacent
if you can get to the same stream by
dropping a single by dropping a single
letter okay so so now we are so the
definition is as before for any two
adjacent streams any an nem but now or
we get not only the output but also the
internal state and some at some
particular point in time and here is
something you can do something
interesting you can do you can let's say
evaluate the density or the number of
distinct elements in your stream so you
shouldn't keep you should keep the
identity of the of the elements secret
of the elements secret and you don't
want to over count you're not simply
counting the number of squares yeah but
you want color to count the number of
different colors that you have and a and
you and given the internal state it
should still be high internal state at
any point in time not all internal state
but the journal stated a particular
point in time it should still be
difficult to determine whether a
particular individual existed or not
okay so just think of it that you're
trying to estimate the number of
distinct users who searched for the term
for the term flu so various things do
not work here in this sort of setting
you you you simply cannot store the
names etc because it's bad for privacy
also for space in simple sampling also
is not good good enough sampling is not
good enough for privacy it's good enough
because you you don't want people to
complain after the fact oh I've been
sampled wise wise all my data exposed
then of course we can sue you okay so
here's here isn't something you can do
so think of it that you come to an
elevator and
you come to an elevator and you want to
and if you don't personally but the
elevator will arrive after a certain
amount of time if you press the button
it will arrive hopefully after last time
it will have a different distribution
but what happens if you press again in a
game well I'm told that it doesn't help
that once you can change the
distribution once so this is the idea
here so initially so we'll have again
this is we start with having a bit for
each potential user of course later on
will sample etcetera we get better
things but think of it for each user
will have a single bit a B X for each
user X will have a single bit bx the
initial distribution of that bit is 0 1
with probability half after we encounter
x each time we encounter x we read we
redraw bx but with a slightly different
distribution will have 0 with
probability half half minus epsilon and
1 with probability half plus epsilon
okay so that we don't when we encounter
x we don't look at all at the bx we
simply redraw a bx according we redraw
bx according to the 2nd distribution and
the final output is the fraction of ones
and the day fractions of one in the
table minus half over epsilon plus a
noise that's how what we make is they
are output this is think of it that we
have just a single output so the claim
is that this is pan private okay so I've
this is the first distribution d0 the
second distribution do you want and the
reason this is a plan private is that
okay so if your user never appeared its
entries drawn from the 0 if it appears
no matter how many kinds of it appeared
its distribution is drawn according to
d1 d0 and d1 are a 4 epsilon
differentially private and this is the
reason why the whole thing is a is
actually pan private you cannot tell
what it is a VN now actually I said
the end so um so you can actually get as
I said you can get improved accuracy in
storage when multiplicative an accuracy
instead of additive accuracy and also a
small storage so so then for the density
here we can get a further density
example we can get epsilon differential
privacy with a error alpha with
multiplicative error alpha in space
which is proportional to polynomial one
over epsilon in polynomial one over a
alpha we can do other things like
estimate the number of users that appear
exactly K times or a cropped means
they're the number of users where that
appeared a certain number of time our
maximum of a certain amount of time a
minimum a certain amount of time we can
estimate the number of heavy hitters the
those it appeared more than their k
times these are all examples of things
we can do and then the things that are
actually hard to do with as I said we
don't have a characterization or a good
hint of what is if it makes a difference
between being able to do it pan
privately and not for continued lock but
we do have a general transformation that
will at least take all non certain
sensitive function and will produce a
continual output version of them okay so
what we get is essentially a dynamic
privacy zoo or a petting zoo with lots
of different criteria we have we have
all possible differentially private the
whole thing is differentially private we
have differential privacy Andrew
continual observation we have panned
privacy and these are some water
orthogonal we have in the intersect not
in the intersection or in their
intersection it's not the intersection
we have
things that are and private under a
continual observation and under
continual intrusions then we have things
that are and inside it we also have
things that behave more like they we
call it the sketching model it scares
the private sketching model that we that
things that we have like a like a
randomized response and although I and
more or less everything in you can see
in this picture you can separate
everything that is not equal you can
actually separate and they oh and then
there is a show of user level Pam
privacy which is again orthogonal to to
the rest and you can read these things
in those papers that are available i
guess various places on my web page in
the microsoft web page etc thank you
thank you so so maybe we can take one
question as we transition speakers we
need to mic oh it's ok ok so quick
question or here in the front please so
actually hold on I have a question on
the remark you made in the middle that
if the user resubmits its answer many
times then it becomes sort of less
private but that's only true if every
draw my coin right because if I just
decide this probability one-half minus
epsilon to lie and then consistently lie
after that no privacy is lost right in
this case in this case no privacy is
lost but you it means that every browser
that rule you you will use you'll have
to use the same say coins and also
whenever you change a little your query
ok so you can simply decide that you're
the lying type and that's it in life of
the
of your life then of course you will be
able will be affected otherwise right
thank you and of course money will be on
the boat where we expect all of you
tonight so you can continue the
conversation there thank you money so
we're going to go we just talk money
talked about privacy and another very
important topic is even if everything is
private what do people think about it
was to user experience and and that gets
us into the trust talk that Jeffrey is
going to talk about Jeffrey short
introduction to take the time we have a
break after we can take a couple more
minutes so Jeffrey is the chief trust
the architecture at Microsoft your
background is in computer graphics so
you could have been working on connect
to maybe but no you went to privacy and
now you've been working on the
end-to-end trust and please start thank
you well thanks for the introduction one
of the visions around end and Trust is
to create a safer more trusted internet
and whenever I mentioned that kind of
concept two people two reactions I
typically get ya one is that it's
intractable the other one is that it's
boiling the ocean both are probably
somewhat true but that doesn't deter me
from at least trying to find ways to
improve the level of trust that we enjoy
on the internet so i want to share with
you some of the methodologies that we're
using to go about that task and within
that area there's one that's a
particular particularly fond of which
has to do with the usability issues of
security and privacy features so i work
in the trustworthy computing group and
in a nutshell i'd have to say what we do
is we're a corporate level group that
helps the company do the right thing so
we focus on things like establishing
security foundations the privacy
standards reliability there's other
things that are in this group at this
point including things like
accessibility
the geo political correctness and even
the green initiatives at the company so
I really have no problem getting up in
the morning because every time that I do
I feel like I'm doing something to
improve things and trying to keep people
honest so the path to end end trust is
actually been quite long for us I'll
just provide a brief history back in
2002 we had a major push that try to
improve the security of our features and
systems and that turned into the
security development lifecycle the sdl
which is available publicly you guys can
take a look at it it's a you know
methodology and process for making more
secure products pretty critical
improvement to software development I
had a lot of opportunity to help on the
privacy side which that also turned into
a standard for how we do privacy and
software development and also not the
mice process for how do you do that with
17,000 developers and actually trying to
get them to do the right thing in that
same time frame there were all sorts of
attacks that we were dealing with
everything from spyware to fishing and
it ultimately turned into identity theft
we sat down and did some deep analysis
trying to figure out three causes of
these things and in the process i also
created this visualization called the
internet battlefield that a number of
people have found useful to see how all
the bad things are happening and then as
you deploy tactics what kind of efficacy
could you expect out of them then in
2007 we actually kicked off an actual
group to focus on some of the usability
issues on security and privacy we call
this tux internally at microsoft it's
short for the trust user experience this
is any time you're placed in the hot
seat trust decision so a team was formed
and also an advisory board in 2008 the
vp of our group the Scotch Arnie
actually wrote a seminal white paper
about end-to-end trust and that's
something I'll go into a little bit and
talk about the ramifications of that in
2008 we also kicked off a team to
actually go off and try to deliver on
the vision that was espoused in the
paper and in 2009 I took over the group
and we have been focused
on other tools and mechanisms to try to
get a little further along given how
hard and how challenging the problem is
so I'll share some of that would work
with you here as well so in the paper if
you've ever had a chance to read and
it's available on the website there's a
link at the end there was a general
sentiment around the need for greater
privacy and security in the internet
there's no great surprise and clearly
having richer connectivity leads to
greater ability to find targets that
could also be very valuable which then
spreads and you know fuels the cyber
crime and a lot of people who are
lamenting about just how anonymous the
criminals were and and just how with
impunity they could about doing what
they're doing and and so it really comes
down to the traceability and
accountability so the paper called for a
couple of key things when it's need for
greater accountability and in many
places where people focus on at any
theft there's always this desire to know
who's who this all stems back from you
know the internet missing the identity
layer during its initial development and
ever since then we've been trying to
catch up trying to put extra capability
and so you know that you're not a dog on
the internet right and having some kind
of useful trust framework would be
important as well and it's important to
note that when you're dealing with the
greater accountability you just want to
make sure you don't do that in the wrong
way such that you started rotating the
personal freedoms we've all come to
enjoy because we don't want this to
become a police state just simply
because we want to find the bad guys so
this is sort of the challenge that ass
arouses kind of kind of work so in the
paper there was a this trusted framework
was proposed and at the bottom you have
the security you have the foundations
layer which provides both you know basic
security capabilities like the sdl
defense and def threat mitigation we
also dovetailed privacy into the sdl as
well at the top you have a lot of the
missing pieces that were called out
earlier about identity everything from
authentication authorization access to
moving to more of the claims based
system and also something that anchors
people in real life some kind of
in-person proofing this is something
that we don't enjoy in any ubiquitous
way today
and only in small pockets do we get
in-person proofing and so we have a real
lack of knowing whether we're really
dealing with the other entity that we
expect there's always this in the center
is really the core it presents a trusted
stack at the bottom obviously if
whatever Hardware you using a suspect l
bets are off so we've seen cases in the
supply chain we're just sore coming
preloaded with viruses and you know
we're kind of worried about what other
chips are there on the keyboards and
stuff like that so yeah supply chain in
it that's all I is very critical so
getting secure hardware's are important
so now we have things like the TPM and
other things that can start to make
assertions about certain trust
statements being made by the system
later on top of that of course is
trusted software we can all spend a lot
of time talking about how this can be
better architected and where it comes
from trusted data you know whether it's
been modified in transit you know does
it still have its integrity and of
course at the top of the trusted people
and and this also includes trusted
devices and trusted entities and clearly
as more and more things connect
everything from the smart grid and
everything else you're going to have to
know what level of trust you have for
the various devices another thing that
was brought up in the paper was that
things won't happen within the ecosystem
to make this vision a reality unless
there's alignment of some key forces in
particular economic political and social
forces a simple example is if there
might be a great technology that might
solve a problem but if a person couldn't
make money at it it may not happen or
there is a really cool technology and
someone wants to make it but
unfortunately you lose your personal
freedoms when you do it so this is big
backlash you know and finally there's
some kind of missing support in the
public policy space for getting certain
things to happen in some cases you need
regulation to actually stimulate some of
the work to happen if there's not an
actual economic force to make that occur
so getting these into alignment is
really the tricky business of a lot of
what we do I can honestly say in the
rest of my talk I do not have a single
epsilon or anything like that it's
really the hard work of trying to get
different people from different places
people who know the smart technology
people learn about policy and people
want to actually spend time doing
standards getting together to make
forward progress
to make this more this happen sooner so
if you looked at the paper it was kind
of it was inspirational a lot of people
picked it up and especially people in
the public policy space looked at it too
and they said this is kind of cool but
it really didn't lay out any kind of
schedule of and kind of a list of who
was going to do which piece so when I
was thrown in my lap it seemed natural
that maybe what we could do at least to
move things on a little bit was to apply
some things we already know how to do
like program management of projects we
do a lot of projects here so we're
pretty good at that we said well why
don't we apply the standard techniques
and let's create a roadmap of what needs
to get done at least that will give us
some kind of framing and a place to have
a discussion because maybe we don't know
the right order to do things so maybe
we're missing some key building blocks
maybe there's certain research that
needs to get done and if people don't
see that stuff early enough it might be
5-10 years before we see some of the big
movements that need to be made so with
respect to roadmaps why would you do
them I'm really fond of creating
visualizations that help all the people
in the ecosystem see the big picture you
need to be able to say oh I'm here and
it's my job to do this piece and oh I
depend on this other person if they
don't get their feast on my pieces in
happening and vice versa I might be
upstream you know downstream from
someone else that needs my piece so
getting people to see what piece they
need to have and how it you candid
mystify all those all those different
dependencies we can start doing the
critical path analysis in particular
things like getting new public policy in
place or creating new standards I think
many of us who have done that town of
work know how long it takes to do so
getting that stuff started early is
really critical and if people knew what
it was for and what it was feeding into
it could might stimulate some of that
work to happen i'm also really kind of
intrigued by are there a bunch of
projects people already doing where the
building blocks can be reused where
there's key components that get used in
other scenarios that people didn't quite
realize so all that's really important
and of course the ability to collaborate
is also very critical so another piece
is that to the extent that people aren't
recognizing that there's something they
can do make some kind of insightful call
to action that there's actually
specific missing piece that needs to get
started maybe you can actually get them
to to think about it so we do a lot of
what we call inspiring and enabling we
don't actually build it necessarily but
we hopefully get other people to realize
the opportunity and then you could also
use these maps to track progress so what
do we think of when we build Rome apt I
think the easiest way to build one out
is to start with something really high
level like an initiative of some kind
something that can help frame the
discussion and maybe get some people in
an audience to say oh yeah that's me I'm
kind of care about that so there's a
couple of big initiatives you can pick
on all this the couple later but one of
them could be like online health care
you know everybody you tell them that
yeah I kind of think that's useful i
might want to do that one day so you
start with something big as big impact
and then you break it down into what
i'll call dream states again this is
nothing special or nothing new this is
just taking standard techniques and
trying to apply it to this problem but
we try to figure out the dream states
and we put on different hats when we do
that in the case of online health care
you know I might take the role of a
patient than I say what's my dream state
well maybe my dream state is who maybe
I'm traveling somewhere and I get
injured and oh I'm allergic to some
special so certain drugs and so when the
doctors find me they're able to access
some kind of special record of mine and
they don't give me a drug that would
kill me and not only that I get better
right away and I don't get charged that
might be my dream state for the online
health care but on the other hand if I'm
a provider or payer I might have a
different dream state around keep them
with costs low things of that nature if
I'm a regulator maybe what I want is to
hit a single button somewhere in some
room and I get all the right auto
reports coming in from various places
and I can tell that everyone in the
ecosystems doing the right thing with
the least amount of work cuz I'm always
understaffed I never have the ability to
do my job well well what if I'm a
researcher well what I want to do is
mine all that data and find where the
latest you know what new drugs might
apply or where the latest diseases are
happening but I want to be able to do
that in a privacy sensitive way so
everyone has a different dream state
depending on the Hat you put on and it's
important to identify these roles and
tease them out because when we go on and
try to you know talk to the ecosystem
everyone has a slightly different pivot
once you have the dream states you break
them down to the next level of specifics
in air
Mario's things that a person is going to
do on a daily basis and we'll talk a
little bit more about scenario
development in a minute but they're
really critical because they tell the
story and once you have the story you
can now start breaking down to the
building blocks the actual pieces it
takes to make these stories happen but
what I like about this process is that
we don't start down here a lot of people
start here they say I've got a really
great building block you should really
love this it's like well what do i use
it for and how does it fit in the big
picture it's a lot easier starting up
here saying do we have a shared vision
of what we want the so often people's
having a dialogue here immediately get
up here and they'll have any common
ground so we kind of like going from
this direction whenever possible and of
course iterating but at this point now
we can maybe tease out the set of
building blocks that are necessary and
map them out over time and actually see
what we've got these could be examples
of things like needing in person
proofing or safe harbor public policies
etc so when we develop scenarios we use
this acronym we specifically try to stay
out of implementation we don't try to
enumerate how it's getting done this
lets a lot more variety of solutions to
show up I mean this is not about windows
solutions or Microsoft solutions about
eco system solutions there's so many
different ways to solve these problems
some of them might be open source
doesn't really matter it's whatever it
takes to solve the problem and you keep
it out of your dysentery development so
you tell a story you use a lot of
personal details you always speak as if
you're the person who you're doing the
scenario for and there has to be some
real research behind do people really
want this this is really Matt well and
it has to be emotional so here's an
example I'm not going to read through it
but this kind of almost the you know
runs through this little script I gave
you about being on a trip and finally
getting better at the end of the day so
you can build these scenarios out now
with respect to initiatives again
they're just tools for framing the
discussion you could have ten
initiatives you could have to it doesn't
really matter we pick these four because
they kind of covered most of the space
the first is the online health care one
I mentioned there's always a little
tagline about needing to say manage the
privacy risk that everybody cares about
when you get to sort of e-commerce and
facilitating that
the people there care more about
reducing the fraud although you'll find
there's a lot of commonality between
these two building blocks that are
necessary a lot of people in government
circles are really afraid of cyber
attacks in cyber warfare espionage you
see a lot of this in the news right now
and so protecting critical
infrastructure really really hot topic
but you've got to be really careful when
you do this because you don't want to
row those personal freedoms this is you
know absolutely critical that we get
this right and build it at the beginning
the ability to possibly d-link
information this once things are linked
up it's almost impossible to pull them
apart and we see a lot of calls for like
a national strategy for secure online
transactions which is now called n stick
but they are out there trying to figure
out how to build that out and if we
don't provide the input right now to
tell them to keep it in balance with
these other abilities to say do minimal
disclosure or the ability not to link
and dean linked data you won't be able
to do it layer and finally another one
that's kind of interesting is secure
online collaboration between virtual
organizations this is sort of the new
way to do business out there you see it
in pharma you see it in aerospace you've
got governments you've got a private and
public enterprise is trying to work
together and quite frankly the problem
in that space if I had to pick a tagline
its managing the distrust between
parties I think you know trying to
increase trust is really not always the
right goal in many ways it's managing
the level of distrust tool to a point or
a level of risk that you're willing to
go through with the transaction that's
more realistic actually and so you've
got these companies that are potentially
competitors with each other who need to
collaborate so they want to share enough
to get it to happen but they don't want
to share too much of their their trade
secrets so one of these entities as an
example for secure collaboration is the
TSE p which is the trans global security
collaboration program and it's out there
right now it's been there out there for
a couple of years and these are all
these very large entities some of them
government and it is trying to work
together for you know the fence and in
some cases these guys might have a bolt
and these guys might have a nut and they
need to be able to put them together but
they don't want to see the engine and
they want to keep people you know
have the right kind of access and
control so their requirements really
push the limits of what's available
right now in technology in terms of
being will have fine grain access
control across many things and be able
to redact document so you only get to
see the things you're supposed to say
they wanted this to work you know where
person has certain access certain role
across all communication channels
whether it's email or documents or
instant messaging or telephone they
would like these things to apply
globally and of course the challenge
here is that this is of course by
definition cross organization and also
cross platform there's all sorts of
stuff in here linux and windows and
whatnot it's going to require all those
other kinds of strategies that we have
at least academically tried to figure
out before but maybe not seen in
products so here is a roadmap for secure
collaboration and don't worry about the
complexity i just want to give you a
quick tour of the colors and what they
mean off on the far right are the dream
states and you can't read it but they're
actually teased out by different roles
in that ecosystem including the
knowledge worker and people who do audit
and various other functions a bunch of
representative scenarios are listed here
and this isn't just something we made up
we actually went to TS CP and we've been
with them for a couple of years now and
they have helped us educate us on what
are their dream states but are there
scenarios so this is now like version 4
of this document so it's not just
something that's just a guess it's kind
of like well they're beginning to say it
smells like them that it actually
represents what they think they want so
after the scenarios you have all these
building blocks sitting out here on the
right hand on the left hand side now the
building blocks come in different colors
in particular the blue ones are
technology building blocks that need to
get done the green ones with the little
books or standards that need to get
established and these guys the ones that
might look yellow to you with a little
house is the public policy ones and
what's kind of cool about this kind of
visualization is just simply having
those three different types of domains
represented on the same space and in
fact trying to illustrate the true
dependencies of these different pieces
as we built this out we were noticing
some strange things number one that
public policy often is not a direct
dependency issue what happens is is
you'll notice they're often dash lines
in this picture
and you can't read the word but it's
accelerator so if you had the public
policy it possibly could accelerate this
to happen of course bad public policy
could decelerate something from
happening so again if if you're trying
to get the full ecosystem engaged and
you've got people in public policy
saying what can we do because we're we
don't quite understand the technology
but tell us what you need this is really
valuable to them because they see where
they show up and when they need to do
the work this has given us an
opportunity to have all sorts of
dialogues at all sorts of different
levels nationally and internationally I
shared this with BMI the German interior
they love the fact that we were trying
to look out over the next couple of
hills because often they're stuck at a
single building block focusing on like
just creating a digital credential
that's the only thing they're focused on
but the nut folk is done any of the
other pieces that are necessary to carry
the rest of the ecosystem so let's look
at the rest of this picture in a little
more detail let's pick a single scenario
i simplified it down this guy just
simply wants to share some documents
other people using some common taxonomy
so they all know bolts of bolt and then
you've got to be able to do it
regardless the application and here are
all the building blocks that tease out
from that scenario and if you actually
started to read through these you'll
notice the clump into certain functions
the first top is all about identity
claims making claims about identity the
middle set have to do with the access
policies related to those identities and
some way of universally representing
those there's a whole suite of them
related to machine health this is the
whole concept of sort of the who model
for computers where I mean the World
Health Organization model for computers
where you know if you have a community
you may not want a particular computer
onto the into that community if it's
been affected and when we right now as a
culture society believe it's okay to
quarantine certain people have certain
kinds of diseases we might feel the same
way about computers and so for these or
communities that they want to make sure
there's people with a certain level of
capability or are certain level
compliance or are not infected the
ability for those machines to make
claims about their health are very
critical so this is actually a really
interesting area to think about so let's
blow up the one on identity claims and
you seek at the different colors we
don't
go through this at all but I'll just
pick well I'll just let me to make this
statement if you were to read one of
these up here you'll realize it's very
generic this is like adoption of
Technology for issuing consuming minimal
disclosure claims this is how you get
less shared you get back to identity
attributes and some other things for
preserving privacy so that's the high
level building block but you know what
are the current projects out there right
now that people could work on or are
working on and when are they coming out
so that's the project level that's a
whole nother level below the building
blocks and you start to tease out what
these projects are across different
companies different spaces now you can
kind of look at the time dimension and
say well are the right things happening
at the right time can we nudge things
long can we incentivize it maybe there's
some program the government needs to do
to fund something maybe there's research
that needs to be done in terms of basic
research let's blow up that green one up
on the right hand corner this is
actually for creation adoption of
interoperability of open standards for
issuing the claims for middle disclosure
and as part of that one of the steps
that we've done recently is to push you
prove technology that we have out into
the public domain so that people could
use it and it's available and you know
people want to go based standards on
that they're welcome to it's not an
issue so that's the kind of stuff that
we had to internally sort of come to
grips with because we were holding up
potentially the ecosystem by sitting on
technology that people couldn't use so
hopefully others will do the same and
then people could build proof of
concepts and we can actually get going
with some of this and get some
experience with it so here's some on the
universal policy side this one over here
is in red and the reason the stars in
red it means it's in progress but
there's something wrong and if you blow
it up you'll realize it's stalled
because there's a couple of different
ways to solve the problem and there
isn't always a common agreement on what
the best practice is so if people could
sort of get off their particular
personal preferences and identify one
and pick it we can now run with it as a
standard so that helps if you can start
picking out where the building where the
roadblocks are then you can can image
those guys along too all right so here's
a road map we put together for online
health care and again I don't want you
to look at any of the details of it
other than look at the topology i'm
going to show you the one
we build for financial transactions okay
here comes watch carefully boy it looks
awfully similar and it's not a great
surprise because they're both in the
same class of high value to Internet
transactions basically it's perceived
that what's transacting over the wires
there is something of high value and
needs to be protected a certain way
where you start seeing differences is
actually in the public policy pieces you
start to see things like patients Bill
of Rights versus safe harbors there's
other kinds of tools to make things
happen and we find that really
intriguing because if we can get a group
of people in one area to sort of take
interest and start moving on it you
suddenly get building blocks available
for other initiatives to for free you
know I have a sort of a dream I hidden
agenda around certain building blocks on
personal freedoms and the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights and if I
were to actually create initiative like
that I probably wouldn't get a lot of
funding but if I could draw it and I can
actually identify the building blocks
maybe there's a bunch already being
built for these other things that we
then could reuse for that purpose so
that's kind of a the way you can think
about using some of these these roadmaps
is pretty interesting okay so if you
were to look at all the stuff that we've
done so far and group all the different
types of building blocks we've seen this
is totally arbitrary but we created
about seven different families of
building blocks I mentioned the ones
relating to health system and device
health there's a whole bunch relating to
identity and claims about that identity
and the authorization and authentication
requirements for that there's a whole
set of things around rules based access
in universal policy in particular I
picked this one as a really rich
research area as there's this greater
desire for the fine-grained control over
things it's going to be a manageable by
humans to basically tag things and label
things at that level it's just going to
be so laborious so tools that
automatically tag intelligently based on
context are clearly a big research area
here and I see this happening more and
more and more will have requirements for
the granularity but we need the
usability and it's going to come through
really interesting architectural
solutions for how to do this the ability
to do reputation you need to know
things beyond some of the self asserted
stuff being able to verify how bad
things happen once they afterwards
through auditing there's a couple of
families that alcohol horizontals that
affect everything in the whole ecosystem
one is the trust user experience which
has to do with the hot seat problem the
usability of these things anytime
there's a uy involved and the other is
the software assurance and integrity
layer about supply chain and things of
that nature you really need to know
where this stuff has gone through and
whether there was a chain of custody and
whether you can trust the actual
components so at this point I'm going to
focus a little bit here on this tuck
stuff and give you a feel for what
that's about so I mentioned sits when
you're in the hot seat and this happens
quite often every time from whether
you're at the right place when you're
trying to do some kind of banking
transaction to whether you've got links
in your email whether you can click on
them this middle one should I share my
data is going to come up again and again
and again we have so many new
cloud-based services emerging some
having do with health care and third
parties are going to want to monetize
your sensitive health records and
they're going to knock on your door with
a horse trade and they're going to say
hey would you mind sharing this data and
your have to figure out whether that's
okay or not we also have people in
social networks making big mistakes here
as well not forming the right mental
models around who gets the data whether
they're truly a friend or not and who
might a friend or a friend of a friend
setting the right permissions this
actually hits a lot of places but also
hits the enterprise space in particular
setting the rolls based access we talked
about also so once we get through this I
think you'll agree that tux is actually
pretty hard to do and do well when we
think about this tux problem we look at
it as a triple we think about the actual
you I a person sees we think about the
underlying architecture and we think
about the users mental model and those
three don't align you get problems you
have people making silly mistakes a lot
of times you will have situations where
the underlying architecture is already
fixed its legacy and you can't change it
so people try to make the UI look more
pretty that doesn't necessarily improve
the users mental model of what's going
on they still might very well not
realize that something is
when it isn't and so on and so forth so
quick example of bad tux and a tux
challenge Here I am I'm about to log in
to my bank and you know one of the
things about the identity theft work is
that the root cause is not knowing who's
who so you do with n occasion but the
challenges most of the time the
authentication is a mutual it's only one
way so this is a great example of that I
log into my bank first tech they ask for
all this information but how do I know
it's then why all i get is this kind of
URL up here to figure out so the
question is well what about that URL is
it correct you know what up here it says
this full name listed out but I don't
know whether that represents this or not
maybe it's just arbitrary but wait a
second i see a lock symbol so it's got
to be safe right this is what most users
think of they've been told lock symbols
mean security but we know here in this
room in a way that this just simply
means that there's a secure connection
between the two eight points so now
you've got a secure channel to the bad
guy sites know of the bad guy can steal
the data they're stealing from you not
not terribly useful but wait a second
you know you know it this lock symbol
you know if anybody can get it you know
part of the problem is first tech is
that even spelled right maybe there's a
dash between there would even notice if
there was a dash what if was felled F
rst since I've been banking with these
guys they've changed their name three
times on the URL so I don't see how an
average user would ever know really what
the right or URL is and use that solely
as the basis for the trust decision well
if you couldn't if you could inspect the
cert maybe you could act the certificate
you might actually find something at
about first tech like where it's located
like is it first tech Croatia or first
tech beaverton oregon that would be kind
of useful so we now have to go in and
actually inspect a certificate and it's
actually does anybody know how to
inspect a certificate how do you expect
a certificate on the on the browser
today please can someone tell me shut it
out if you know only one person how do
you do it
no thanks Josh was close you actually
double click the lock symbol okay so if
you double click this lock symbol you
actually get this screen which tells you
about the certificate now can someone
tell me where is the relative
information about the organization and
the location of that organization of
where they are in the world anybody know
issuer statement not quite right first
off who did the checking of this entity
who is the actual company that's doing
the checking secure server certification
authority doesn't even know what company
that is that's verisign now back when I
grabbed this off the web that's how they
used to publicly publicize themselves so
you know if you thought verisign did
good checking how would you know is even
variscite well the issue a statement
will tell you what they checked and how
much was paid for this kind of
certificate you know there's a class
three certificate which is for banks and
its really expensive they do a lot of
checking but how would you know that as
a user unless you've got to this level
and read the issuer statement which is a
legalese document well anyway let's just
skip over all that let's just pretend
you know what you're doing here so you
can't really know whether you you have
this branded there is this details tab
that's kind of intriguing so let's click
on that and see if we can find the where
this thing is located aha we now can see
all the fields in the certificate can
someone tell me what field in the
certificate carries the location
information of the place that's been
checked of where they're located does
anybody know okay it's the subject field
and if you double-click the subject
field you get these set of values
organization first tech credit union
location Beaverton State Oregon Country
us this is the most relevant trust
information of the entire web right here
five levels deep in the interface all
right that scares the they I don't
know about you but this is just really
way too hard right this is why we have a
tux problem because the trust
informations buried here and it's not
even clear you could trust these fields
are these self asserted fields in the
certificate or they actually checked by
the significant authority well guess
what you know verisign might charge a
thousand dollars for their certificate
what about godaddy the charges 1999 do
you think they check these fields do you
think
drive by this location to verify it's
there no they don't all they need to do
is just verify that you own the path the
URL so this information could be garbage
anyway so the question is how do you
make this easier for users well this is
a tux challenge so what we did is we
spent maybe two years with the other
browser vendors and all the ca's all the
certificate authorities to come up with
a new standard called extended
verification certificates has anyone
ever seen this green bar okay does
anybody know what it means what what
does the green bar mean okay great
another text problem so green bars mean
there's an extended verification
certificate in play a special
certificate that paypal bought that all
the certificate authorities are
guaranteed due to a minimum level of
checking dr5 location make sure they got
money in the bank make sure the person
who's asking for it is in the mailroom
clerk but someone is actually going to
take a fall if there's a problem like
their legal counsel or their CEO all
right so some high level person in the
company is the one who gets it issued
and so all this checkings been done now
all the browser vendors said if we ever
encounter one of these EV certs we will
color it differently will present it
differently in the UI it's green and
we'll also populate at the very top
level the name of the entity and where
it's located so you don't have to go
five levels deep we would like to
believe this is trust at a glance write
clearly and it could be perceived as an
improvement if you knew the semantics so
now that you all now understand the
semantics of the green bar and then it's
a shorthand the next time you encounter
one of these you can say well that's
great i can now just click away because
I know exactly what this is and it
really is my bank but then the bad guys
come in and they do one of these little
tricks this is a picture of picture
attack and we actually just study where
everything in this window over here as
you know is arbitrary it's just pixels
drawn by this website all this is
arbitrary and so this is actually evil
pale paypal com up here no green bar no
lock symbol and they put you a picture
of a green bar with the lock symbol and
forty percent of the people who I just
gave the talk to now think this is safe
and click away and put in their password
so we have a fundamental problem here
this is the trusted pixels problem with
the Providence of a pixel
and the problem is is that everything up
in here is special to the designers it's
called the chrome of the UI it's where
you put your security indicators here
and down here and this other little bar
going around the site is all special but
all of this inside is arbitrary now how
many users really understand that and
can they pick and distinguish between
these arbitrary pixels and these pixels
that are special quite frankly as
designers most designers delude
themselves into thinking users can tell
the difference semantically of one set
of symbols from another and it's worse a
lot of websites will actually take lock
symbols and put them gratuitously all
over the page sometimes without any SSL
at all any kind of security and that
further dilute whatever values they have
so tux is a really hard problem we have
to get away from all this we have to use
real science to figure out what works
for people what doesn't work for people
clearly this is an interesting risk does
anyone banking bankofamerica okay they
have this cool little feature called
site key which gives you a visual secret
okay so the idea is you pick some visual
secret that's neat unique to you and
when you log in the next time you're
supposed to see this secret and feel
really good and comfortable that you're
at the right site and it's not a bad guy
right so the researcher this is Stuart
Schechter over an MSR and and some of
his colleagues instead of putting up the
picture they put up this little thing
bank of america is currently upgrading
our award-winning psyche feature please
contact customer service if your psyche
does not reappear with the next 24 hours
of all their subjects ninety-two percent
gave their credentials to the bad guy so
what does this tell you from a tux
perspective it says that the absence of
a visual secret has no efficacy people
don't recognize the absence of something
and so it really doesn't have a lot of
value and of course you ask Bank of
America about why do you keep using it
as a security feature it says all it's
not a security feature just makes our
users feel better doesn't make them
safer so a lot of research still
opportunity here trying to figure out
what kinds of tools can we offer people
that give them higher confidence of
making trust decisions so the vision for
tux for consumers anyway
is how do you make them safer more
confident while not distracting them
from enjoying their digital lifestyle
and I say this it's really important
because security and privacy are not
primary tasks for users most consumers
it's the last thing they want to do they
want to chat with friends they want to
go online they want to watch a movie
they do not want to set up their
security so how do you then get them
safer while not blocking them and for
businesses if you really think about it
this has been a disaster I mean all
email that I get I'm supposed to ignore
all the links that are in that email so
my bank can't even communicate with me
they say please go to our website so we
can have a dialogue so you get a walled
garden situation and clearly when bad
tuxes occur not just for consumers but
you can imagine a bad tux for an
enterprise where you're doing some kind
of roles based access and you set the
wrong kind of access permission and
suddenly you've reached a million
records so the scale factors are huge in
an enterprise for bad talks for
administrators and I'll show you some
examples of this in a minute so there's
been quite a bit of research that we've
even par taken on this there's also
other groups there's this whole event
called soups which is actually happening
this week at Microsoft on Wednesday
Thursday and Friday the symposium of
usable privacy and security and the
latest researcher in this space is
actually happening right now at the
commons in two days but I'll talk about
some of these things let me pick off
this expandable grid because it's really
interesting a researcher at CMU is
name's Rob Reider for his thesis he said
I'll take a look at the access control
editor in Windows for setting
permissions and he realized that there's
some really funny semantics here when
you can allow something and deny
something and when you're also part of a
group or an individual and so when you
have any combinations of these two
concepts it becomes really hard for the
average user to figure out what's going
on and it actually takes 19 separate
screens to do an action where you're
trying to get the permissions to be
correct I'm just a fly through this so
first you have to inspect the actual
permissions the user has then you've got
to figure out what groups there in then
you got to figure out what permissions
that group has then you've got to go in
and actually change the permissions and
then you've got to go back and check
your work 19 separate screens
well the reason this is so bad is
because the key information is
distributed across multiple different
tools and so while groups have one
concept individuals have another trying
to blend them together is kind of
challenging and it's really easy to make
silly mistakes when you have that kind
of level of complexity and algorithms so
it would be much better if you can
directly check and manage the permission
so we came up with a really elegant
solution for this i'm using this just as
an example of what a whole a tux pattern
that might be useful to use again and
again so we came up with this thing
called the expandable grid it's pretty
elegant down one side you have the
things you're trying to manage
hierarchically and across the top you
have groups and individuals
hierarchically and anytime you get an
intersection it's green if you've got
access red if you don't and yellow means
that there's some mixed access and if
you want to find out why it's yellow you
can just click on the box and dive in
and once you're there you can add a very
fine grain if you want to give someone
the permission with one click now this
is a lot better the 19 screens so if you
start using some metrics you start
measuring stuff you can actually say
well how accurate is this new method
over the old one yellow is the new
method and blue is the old one and
you'll notice on the accuracy side for
some of these tasks no one got it right
and 61 percent of the people got right
here is ninety percent right nobody got
it right and I've highlighted the ones
that were statistically relevant out of
the 36 different possible outcomes here
14 significant results statistically
significant and wildly so in the case of
accuracy way off the scale in the case
of how fast it was to do about three
times as fast so this is big news i
think i think if we could figure out
ways to craft these cool patterns based
on the kinds of actions we're trying to
solve we could reduce the silly mistakes
people are making and they'll actually
enjoy using security and privacy a
little more something to think about we
investigated things like secret
questions this is a Sarah Palin problem
you know she you know someone broke into
her account and took over her her her
information because it was like what was
your favorite sports team if you know
anything about their location it's very
easy to guess but some of the most
statistically guessable answers are
things like your grandfather's
occupation we
tired or dead or the two top answers
favorite historical person would be
Jesus or Lincoln or you know Martin
Luther King you could pick some of those
what's also interesting is they also
check how often people forgot their
answers so if this is what's being used
as state of the art for getting back
into your account as your last resort
riya sen occasion after being blocked
this is one of the weakest things you
could possibly do you've got to pick
some of the questions at the lowest ones
in particular like you know the name of
your old dog or something like that
something somebody's not going to guess
very easily but not your current dog
it's probably on facebook all right so
just to wrap up warnings there's so many
different types of tuxes warnings just
one class there's prods there's warnings
there's consents there's all sorts of
Texas one of the rules of thumb that we
have about Texas no tuxes good tux if
you could avoid engaging the user in the
first place that's a wonderful place to
be if you could solve it in the
architecture Godspeed great idea but in
general sometimes you still have to get
a warning in front of someone so if you
have to warn you should do so in such a
way that by default the person is safe
and you don't interrupt them from what
they're trying to do there's nothing
worse than having to stop what you're
doing to actually address a warning and
this is a gold bar you might have seen
this in IE internet explorer for activex
controls it used to be that an activex
control when you visit our website would
just pop up saying I need to be loaded
yes no and you had to answer it and you
couldn't go any further unless you did
now what happens is that kind of content
gets put on a gold bar and it says hey
there is some other work you need me
want to do here but it's optional it's
up to you and ninety-nine percent of the
time you don't need that extra stuff in
the case of trying to open up a file
that might have dangerous content the
strategy is put it in the sandbox and
then let the person know that some
things were disabled and if they still
want to get into it to really kind of
look at it and they can do some
additional trust tests then they can
enable the content but don't by default
just enable the content and don't block
them as often you just want to remember
what that thing was you don't really
need all the attachments and things like
that and it's really frustrating for
users when they can't get to what they
want to do and then if you do have to
interrupt give them some kind of
realistic steps to follow this is all
about the quality of the guidance
so I'm as my last slide here the open
questions I think for the research
community and in tucks land is quite a
few of them and if you go to the
conference you'll hear a lot more but
one of the questions was even if we were
to provide an interruptive warning that
was were all written in an actual what
people actually respond to in such a way
that would avoid attacks and you know
what's the to efficacy of a warning and
how often does it really play into safer
results and also for class of users what
can we realistically ask them to figure
out and finally you know when should we
warn versus just taking action there's
this whole idea that if you if a person
is not going to be well equipped to
answering the question just don't ask
them and that either means don't ask
them because you're going to take an
action or don't ask them because you
won't take an action and what's the
liability of not taking an action when
you knew there was a risk but it isn't
helping just popping warnings in front
of people that they can't act on so
these are the open research areas i'll
add two more the list this is one of my
favorite what is the sweet spot for
informed consent and how do we get there
how many people have actually read there
you lose and privacy statements when
they pop up saying click here to say
you've read 45 pages of content clearly
informed consent doesn't work all right
you have feel safer not reading them so
the question is what's the sweet spot
well if you're the person who's trying
to offer the service you love it when
people don't read it so you're sweet
spots probably right where it is right
now but as a consumer or a person who's
getting the service what do you want to
know about the horse trade what is
useful to you to assess whether it was
in your best interest or not and this is
one of the tux metrics which is
measuring regret which is after you
learn about the behavior of a consent
experience you said yes to would you
have wished you had said no that's about
the only way you can measure some of
these things and it's kind of
interesting stuff so I'd love people to
get more into this and get us to a point
where informed consent actually means
something and finally how do we
facilitate minimal disclosure there's a
lot of desire here to preserve privacy
of only sharing the middle amount of
data across a trust boundary but how do
you present that and how do you get a
user to select Lily choose attributes
about their identity at granularities
that makes sense
right now almost all the patterns we've
seen for this kind of you I have failed
and people haven't figured out how to
actually pass over that transom with the
right information and so they're still
passing too many too much data so anyway
this is just some of those open things
so thank you so much for your time if
you want to read more about end-to-end
trust there's a whole website on that
the soups conference is actually
starting on Wednesday there's tutorials
i believe and then the actual paper
sessions fri thursday and friday and if
you want to actually collaborate on any
of this or you want to take a look at
those road maps and provide some
feedback feel free to contact me and we
can see if we can work something out
thank you thank you very much